pense que ça montre que là c'est
celle-là commis son enquête la
commission des lois pousse un peu plus
loin que jusqu'à présent les fonctions
de commission d' enquête parlementaire
et c'est bien et d'ailleurs l'intérêt de
cette nouvelle salle d'audition c'est de
mettre en évidence les
dysfonctionnements de l'exécutif en la
matière que ce soit en termes de
passeports diplomatiques on peut pas les
désactiver ce que nous alliés ministère
de l'intérieur la dernière fois alors
qu'il ya eu des des procédures en cours
concernant monsieur benalla et qu'il a
été licencié comme la quelqu'un de
l'elysée lui rendent ces passeports en
lui expliquant bon tu peux les utiliser
ça fait ça fait un peu désordre et et le
rôle autant la recherche de la vérité
c'est le rôle de la justice autant
pointer les dysfonctionnements de
l'exécutif c'est bien là d'une
commission d' enquête parlementaire doit
sous c'est son rôle est là très
clairement on s'aperçoit qu'elles sont
complémentaires et qu'on arrive à
pousser avec sedan se doit ce cas là une
jurisprudence un peu différent de ce
qu'on avait jusqu'à présent terme de
deux commissions d'enquêté c'est
intéressant parce qu'on aura plus de
contrôle du parlement sur l'exécutif ci
après compte-tenu voilà de ce qui a été
fait de ce qu'a répété le président de
la commission des lois aujourd'hui et je
crois que c'est bon et ça montre aussi à
quel point le sénat est un est un
contre-pouvoir qui est utile et qui dont
les pouvoirs peut progresser ça ne
dépend que de lui